Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to a new
episode of 13 o'clock how is everyone
doing out there I know that you can't
answer me okay so what do we have
what's this one going to be round well
wait wait a minute before we get started
let's do let's give a shout out again to
project Entertainment Network on which
our audio version of the podcast is host
to go to their patreon at patreon.com
slash project and Smith and give them a
buck or two they have some cool swag and
like I said I think I mentioned it last
week but we have a new like a special
edition like t-shirt that is going to be
available in the project Entertainment
Network store so if you like that design
better than the ones that I did then
well you don't but you know but it's the
ones that are on our store and you can
go over there they have an exclusive
yeah yeah yeah they have an exclusive
it's like a different logo one it's
pretty right looks pretty cool yeah and
then also what was the other saying oh
um you guys you guys I just if you like
like our paranormal topics and stuff
like that I just finished my new
poltergeist book the unseen hand
I just finished recording the audio
version and everything yeah so this is
going to be like a benchmark book in in
culture guys studies yeah it's like
hundreds went over a hundred cases like
120 cases something like that like going
way back to the first century and just
all the bolts are guys cases you know
and love are all in there and they're
all summarized and some of the ones in
most of them never heard of yeah I tried
to find some more obscure ones feel like
you know I couldn't put every single one
in the world and they're obviously
because that route would be like with I
would be dead before I would finish it
and if you haven't read any of James
books they're awesome it's not so much
like a show the show we only have a
couple days to research these topics
which is a book she spent months on it
they're really yeah and they have a lot
more highly rated on Amazon they so well
but
I think a lot of people are interfering
I wonder why this book this is kind of
like that guy who's that guy back in the
60s used to write all those normal
Brooks well like it well I used to read
William roll it's like a million rules
he's like parapsychologists and he word
a lot of stuff like when I was growing
up in the 70s and early 80s like seem
like most of his books were in the
library and I was reading a bunch of
those here but yeah it's kind of like
that it's like a compilation of cases
and also kind of an overview of the
phenomena and yada yada and it came out
really good big fat book and it'll be of
the print and ebook version will be up
probably next week and then like the
week after that the audio version will
probably be up because it takes them a
while to go through the quality control
and stuff like that yeah it's all in the
can it's just going through the final
process yeah yeah such dull technical
[ __ ] from this point on out and also and
this is a nice segue into our topic
today because the next book I'm thinking
about writing I'm thinking about doing a
true-crime compilation of like unsolved
murders or unsolved serial murders or
both yeah and I came up with a tie
before yeah it is a really good man I
could forgotten on titled no I remember
it should I say yeah that's it oh you
get yes it's going to be called faceless
villain basis villain yeah he came up
with that it with that title I'm like
whoo I like it and we were out walking I
cannot wear this time yeah I think I
think I'm going to come up with that
case but Jenny's memory is better than
mine I don't know I don't like that it's
just part of it and then he forgets I
will have to come write it down because
otherwise I'll forget it too yes but um
the reason I mentioned that is because I
[ __ ] love true crimes man and I
especially love unsolved murders like I
don't love them because people dead
because that's bad but but it's like
they really get my imagination going
because you know it's so intriguing like
thinking what could have happened like
you know and all of them are so weird
like especially like the weird ones is
like all these weird unexplained details
oh hold on oh I forgot to mention
something what'd you forget
Oh James didn't go on a promotional tour
online for the way my book comes out
we've already had we already have some
stuff lined up we have a couple shows we
normally go on one of them is in a date
radio
who else was where the road on that
yeah that's not well you'll be on that
one I didn't write the books I won't be
honest but Jenny will be a guest on
those and as the dates come up we're
going to post notifications in both
streams both in YouTube and in the audio
audio but yeah way you guys can listen
to her shows yeah you'll know what date
they come out yeah some of them might be
live hangouts too because that they do
that sometimes also every now and then
yeah I've got a couple rows but yeah so
that'll be upcoming so that's all
upcoming stuff so anyway let's go back
to okay now I discovered this case and I
thought that I was pretty up on my
creepy unsolved murder what's the name
of this kind of [ __ ] this is called
generally is usually called the mystery
in room 1046 or horror in room 1046 I've
seen it called both things and I
actually actually stumbled across this
on like a subreddit thread about true
crimes and it was like the third most
popular story and I had never heard of
it I never heard of it yeah so like I
went in there and started researching
and stuff like that it turned out that
like a couple lost it was like last year
or last Halloween or something like that
I think cracked.com you know every
Halloween they do like a bunch of like a
list of like creepy unsolved murders and
stuff and I think it was one of the ones
in there but you know it was just giving
short shrift I think and but some of the
details about those case are super
[ __ ] weird and has never been solved
right right so what I'm going to do like
I kind of I broke down like I laid out
the timeline and I'm just going to lay
it all out you can look kind of comment
on like these kind of weird little
details and also like that I mean you'd
like to use my street sense yeah I mean
boiler alert the guy dead I mean that
yeah but like I said no the entry yeah
we know that you know that's what
happens at the end but um but you know I
think the interesting thing about it is
like all the creepy little details that
they never figured out let's set the
scene right it's January 2nd 1935 Kansas
City 1935 Kansas is yes it is can you
picture it
yes you can so that's winter shot Oh
second day after New Year's all right
there's a hotel called the hotel
president this young man was dark hair
like dark brown hair walks in the door
he doesn't have any luggage right and
you know people that saw him he was
obviously young but people kind of
pegged his ages like somewhere between
20 and 35 so you know also hit a
cauliflower ear so people like kind of
read him as maybe a boxer or a dealer
yeah okay yeah so he comes in no luggage
he specifically asked for an interior
room several floors up she doesn't owe
any windows no windows
um he signs the register roland teo in
who says he's from los angeles he pays
for one day
now the bellboy comes to take him up to
the room now the bellboy remembers that
the main thing that the guy did was he
bitched that he had stayed in the in
another hotel the night before called
the mullah bak and these like highway
robbers had tried to charge him five
whole [ __ ] dollars for an interior
room now I know that doesn't sound like
much but in 1935 $5 was the equivalent
of about $90 today so you know you can
see why he was doing but that's
specifically what the bellboy remember
he said he was just complaining about
the other hotel so they go up to they
give him a room on the tenth floor with
no windows and the bellboy sees this guy
he goes into the room he shows him into
the room and this role in t ohen guy all
he takes out of his pocket is a comb and
a brush and a tube of toothpaste that's
it and he puts him down in the bathroom
all right and then he says okay well I
you know I got to go out so the bellboy
was like okay well I'll walk down with
you because I'm going down there jail
now
Roland leads the door to his room
unlocks and the bellboy said hey do you
mind if I go back and lock the door and
I was like sure so he give him the key
the guy goes back and locks the door and
then he comes and then he sees the guy
leave now this was like this was
Wednesday January 2nd this was the
morning now about noon that same day the
maid comes up to clean the room she
knocks on the door
and Roland answers and she's kind of
surprised because you know there was
someone else staying in there and she'd
been off a day she's been off the day
in-between so she said oh I didn't know
anyone was in here you know I'll come
back later and you know Roland says now
it's all right you can come in and clean
or whatever so she comes in to clean and
then he says don't lock the door because
I have a friend coming over in a few
minutes
now the maid also noticed that every
time she went into the room like all the
the blinds were always drawn really
tight and it was always super dark in
there it's like he just had like one
little lamp like on by the bed and
that's the only light she ever saw on
and there was always like really dark so
she's cleaning the room and stuff and
then Roland goes into the bathroom
Church brushing his hair and then he
reminds her again Haley the door unlocks
because I have a friend coming okay but
she didn't see anybody come in and she
didn't see him leave she finishes
cleaning as she leaves now four o'clock
she comes back to the room and she's got
the towel you know from the laundry she
comes into the door was still unlocked
and she goes in there the room is still
dark but she sees Roland in there and
he's laying across the bed fully dressed
in the dark and evidently he doesn't say
anything to her and she doesn't say his
name she just leaves the towel and then
on the dresser she sees a note and it
says dawn I will be back in 15 minutes
wait but he was in the room and he was
just laying there in the dark on the bed
with all his clothes on like he was
getting ready to leave like he was
getting ready to leave but she didn't
mention that he said anything too or
anything like that she said it was just
really creepy because he was just laying
there on the bed in the dark so like no
one hears anything that night so the
next morning which was Thursday January
3rd and the same maid she goes up to
room 1046 around 10:30 and she's going
to clean it now for some reason she
assumed that Roland was not in there so
she used her passkey to open the door
now the way this hotel was situated I'm
not sure I don't know if
works this way anymore but you can only
like the staff can only open the door
with their passkey if the door had been
locked from the outside so she opens the
door with her passkey which means that
someone had locked the door from the
outside which I guess is why she assumed
that Rowland wasn't in there but when
she went in there he was in there he was
just sitting there in the dark so she's
like well he couldn't have gone out in
lhasa door someone else was gone out and
locks the door and had the key because
you know how else would it be locked she
would have been able to unlock it so
he's just sitting there in the dark then
she heard the phone ring sir Roland
picks up the phone and she hears him say
no Don I don't want to eat I'm not
hungry I just had breakfast and then he
just kept saying no I'm not hungry so
then like Roland hangs the phone up and
then he starts like chatting with the
maid you know saying oh you know two
people live in this hotel you know are
you cleaning the entire floor blah blah
blah and then he bitched again about the
hotel the night before trying to charge
him $5.00 for the interior room because
actually was really sticking in his craw
evidently he's like that goddamn trying
to charge him five dollars five so the
maid finishes cleaning up the room she
leaves now this is the same day Thursday
4:00 p.m. she comes back again from the
laundry with the towels and this is the
same neighbor full time she comes up she
knocks on the door she hears two nuns
talking in the room and now a voice
asked her who is that and she said it
didn't sound like Roland voice different
guys she said I was just the bait I came
with the clean towel and the voice says
we don't need any and tells her to go
away now she knows that there's no
towels in the [ __ ] room because you
took the dirty ones earlier and she you
know she's bringing the clean one she's
like okay well okay you need herself
even they do because they're got it now
here's like here's something a little
weird now later that night about 11:00
p.m. there's a guy named Robert Lane and
he was driving down the street near this
hotel the hotel president that Roland
was staying at he said he was driving
along the street
and he suddenly saw this guy running
down the road and he said the guy had
shoes and pants on but he just had an
undershirt like him to have a coat or
anything since January with a freezing
cold but it really you know it was
pretty cold he's running down the street
and undershirts
so the guy like waves Robert laying down
in the car hey hey hey
so Robert Lang stops the car and he says
the guy comes up to a car and then kind
of looked at him like oh I thought this
was a taxi right and he's like um can
you take me to where I can get a cab and
he and Robert Lane is like sure he said
and then he says to the guy he said I
said you look like you've been in it bad
because he looked kind of distraught and
we were too beat up he said he looked
like on his forearm there was this
really long deep cut now Robert Lane
said that this man said I'll kill that
blank tomorrow
that's the newspaper put of blank so I
don't know if it was I'll kill that
[ __ ] tomorrow kill that [ __ ]
tomorrow
kill that bath mat you're getting a
front it looked like it yeah if this was
indeed the same guy because they're not
entirely sure but Robert Lane you know
he he lets this person get in the back
seat of the car and he takes them down
the street to where there's like a cab
or something like that and he says the
guy is like cuffing his hands like in a
strange way as though he had another
wound somewhere else and was trying to
like catch blood from it or something
like that that's what the guy said
anyway so he said I dropped the guy off
he said I saw the guy get out of the car
he went over to the cab and the cabbie
wasn't in there so he said the guy goes
over to the driver side of the cab and
like honks the horn of the cab which I
thought was how cheeky and then Robert
Lane said oh I thought a cabbie who was
a restaurant across the street come
running out like hey okay there's a fare
now they don't know for sure because
Robert Lane only said that he saw this
guy and that this guy was the same guy
rolling see Owen after the murder
happened okay okay so shown pictures
with yes and yes so he said that yet
so they're not entirely sure but still
because they could you know if this if
the guy was like running around like
with just an undershirt and something
like that you think you think that the
staff at hotel would have noticed him
running out of the hotel but maybe he
was coming from somewhere else this is
my this is the question I have city had
a wound on his arm
doctor he said he said it was a very
deep cut was that on the dead body yes
okay so yeah probably was yeah but like
I said you know all they have is Robert
lanes words like hey I picked that guy
up the other road later that night after
this car incident evidently there was a
woman named Jean Owen no relation and
she was staying in room 1048 which was
next to Sun 46 and she said she told
police that she heard two men and two
women arguing and cursing she wasn't
sure if it was coming from 10:46 but she
said she knew it was on the same floor
because it was really loud now she said
the noise went on for a while and she
was going to report him but then it
stopped so she didn't hear was another
thing that was kind of like I said
there's all these like weird little
details and they're not really sure like
what had what was relevant to the case
or whatever because they don't know if
all that arguing was from that room or
not she said she thought it was because
it was really noisy and she was right
next door now there was also there was
an elevator operator and he worked the
night shift now he saw a this woman she
came in the elevator and she asked to go
up to the 10th floor and the elevator
operator had seen this woman before she
was a hooker right and but she asked for
room 1026 now there's some kind of
confusion about this because when the
story about the murder first went out on
the wire service they actually
identified the room that Roland t ohen
had been staying in as 10:26 but it was
actually 1046 so they're not really sure
if this hooker was asking to go to
Roland's room so she asked for 1026 now
the elevator operator took her up to the
10th floor and she took
now about five minutes she came back and
signaled for the elevator again and the
elevator operator said oh the guy I'm
supposed to meet isn't in his room and I
wonder why because he's always been you
know on time in a one-bedroom so yes so
they're not really sure and she said
maybe he's in a different room maybe he
was in 1024 because I saw mice on in
there but she's like I don't know he you
know he's not in there so she waited
around for about half an hour about 40
minutes they said and up there now then
the elevator operator got called again
to go to the tenth floor and she came
out and she went down and left in the
lobby in about an hour later she came
back with another beard and I an unknown
dude and um she went up to the ninth
floor with this guy and then about 4:15
a.m. she came out and she left the hotel
and then about 15 minutes later the man
came down and he left herself because he
said he couldn't sleep okay now she's in
this case because she may have
originally been going to see this guy
right they're not sure because the room
she had for like I said there was
confusion about which room it was
initially yeah and they thought it was
weird that she had done it to the room
and she's like oh he's not in there and
I'm not really sure what room I'm
supposed to go then other than that
little reference she doesn't really play
right they're not sure they're not sure
because these were like the only people
that were kind of that we're seeing that
we're not really you know they don't
really know like who they were they
weren't really accounted for yeah
so yeah now then it was Friday morning
7:00 in the morning and then the
operator in the hotel she noticed that
the phone in room 1046 was off the hook
and no one was using it right and this
is the one where the guy with the got it
was the one where the guy was saying the
phone was off the hook and she well can
you tell somebody just has the phone off
well I guess well in my 35 didn't they
have the little switchboards there must
a little light or something yeah that's
I mean so because I guess they knew like
when I rush it was off the hell can they
knew when someone wasn't using it maybe
they could listen in I'm not sure okay
I'm not real familiar with phone
technology thirty five so she's kind of
like ha Mossad so she gave it about ten
minutes and then it was still off the
hook and no one was using it so she told
the bell boys you know felt there and
tell him to hang that phone up now the
bell boy that went up there was the same
Bell boy who had shown Roland Owen to
the room on the first day when he
checked in now he goes up there and the
door was locked and there's a Do Not
Disturb sign on there so the bellboy
knocks and no one answers then he knocks
again and then a voice says come in
except he couldn't come in because the
door was locked from the inside
all right right so he knocks again and
he's like you know hey it's lost and
then the same voice said turn on the
lights even though he couldn't come in
the door was laughs so how could the
lights on I don't know so he just keeps
knocking and knocking and then he gets
no answer and then finally he yells
through the door put the phone back on
the hook right so then he goes back down
to the lobby and he tells the operator
you know I don't know the [ __ ] guy in
there guys [ __ ] drunk or something
like that he's like shouting me just
open the door and I can't about her
doors block is telling me turn the
lights on I can't even get in there so
he's like I don't [ __ ] know I told
him to put it back on the hook so he
says you know wait about an hour Stevens
back on the hook if not we'll we'll send
someone else up there actually this is a
good time to pause and take a break
because we're almost about the halfway
point let's take a break right now and
then we will continue this creepy
[ __ ] story in just a few minutes
we'll be right back it was a time when
we raced to the TV Guide to see what was
playing on monster movie matinee at
Saturday afternoon and in some cities
that evening it was all about werewolves
vampires giant lizards and those great
Japanese monster movies relive it all
every week as Jim Adams and Mark Maddux
bring you monster attack monster attack
takes
look at those classic monster movies
that we all grew up loving join us every
week on monster attack exclusively on
the project Entertainment Network
subculture corsets in clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing checkout
subculture online at subculture corsets
calm that subculture corsets calm make
sure you use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount subculture
corsets calm or visit their store in
Jacksonville Florida just off i-95 the
narrow casting you on the broadcast the
Brett's [ __ ] and heavy metal properties
with a common connection brought you my
house token John Clark
max max smoking hold Hades and ours real
Mordechai featuring interviews and all
with the stars melon floor
the necro casting on Mondays on protocol
and extremist Network Hollow Earth
graphic the dime by Jenny Ashford
specializing in posters and flyers
special rates for fans at heart
quick turnaround times books and CD
covers
consultations through email or Skype
logos and packaging
payment through PayPal
as in trouble materials satisfaction
guaranteed visit the Facebook pages
Hollow Earth design or email Hecky 8 at
hotmail.com ok we're back so when we
last left you know like I said phone was
off the hook so 8:30 a.m. the operator
sees the phone is still awesome so she
sends a different bellboy just go up
there and tell him to put the phone back
on that so the second bellboy goes up
there and the door was locked but this
time he uses his pass key in the door
open which means in the meantime someone
must have gone out and lost the door
from the outside
ok right so this bellboy his name was
Harold Pike person was named Randolph
something
but Harold Pike he goes in there and he
can see in the room like there's light
from the hallway and [ __ ] like that and
he says now this time he sees Roland
Owen and he's lying on the bed naked ok
and the any looks drunk
okay now the telephone stands which had
a glass top had been knocked over so
that that was why the phone was off the
Hut okay so all the bellboy did he did
you know he's he's just like Oh maked
guy drop guy in bed he must have not
just hang over with his arm or whatever
so he puts it back he puts the phone
back and puts it back on it say so then
he goes back downstairs and he tells a
supervisor another [ __ ] disease drunk
up there he just knocked it over I fixed
it
okay so then around 10:30 10:45 operator
sees that the phone is off the hook
again right after the guy went up there
and fixed it and saw the guys sit laying
there naked
so the first bellboy Randolph he goes up
there and he's um
Do Not Disturb sign is on the is on to
say Holland or on the door murder so he
knocked gets no answer so he had lost
over this past key this is not the
service son was not there before it was
got put up here so he's still alive he's
sleeping on the bed
yeah because do not disturb on it yeah
either him or someone else we'll see
that's the thing it must have been
someone else because the door was locked
from the outside right so someone had
the key and came out and locked it
alright because you can't I guess you
can't do that like all the reports that
you can't okay so okay so this so this
time
Randolph goes up he seems to do not
disturb sign he knocks there's no answer
he unlocks it over his passkey meaning
it was locked from the outside now when
he goes in this time this was his
statement to police he said when I
entered the room
this man was within two feet of the door
on his knees and elbows holding his head
in his hand
I noticed blood on his head I turned the
light on placed the telephone receiver
on the hook I looked around and saw
blood on the wall and in the bathroom
what man just a man yeah the man in the
room okay alright the man in the room
he said yeah so blood all over the walls
and the guy was on the floor of his head
his hands and there was blood on his
head so the bellboy you know runs
downstairs gets a supervisor gets all
this other stuff so also all of the
supervisors a manager everything like
that they run back up to the room now
this time they try to open the door and
they can only open it about six inches
because Roland Owen has fallen in front
of the door okay so you know they call
the cops they call a doctor they call or
an ambulance or whatever so they all
come up there now the guy roll and see
Owen is still alive however he has been
restrained with cords there's a rope
around his neck around his wrists and
around his ankles he looked like he had
been tortured
there were several knife wounds above
his heart one of these knife wounds
punctured his lung
he had also been beat on the head a
bunch of times it was like a big wound
it was also bruising on his neck you
know so probably someone had tried to
strangle him now they said the room was
just shattered with billy was blood
everywhere it was just on the furniture
was on the ceiling it was all over the
place which is weird because the first
fell boy that went up there hadn't
noticed that all right he just noticed a
guy laying there naked he hadn't noticed
blood all over the wall
so the doctor is there and he cuts the
the cords like off Owens
risks and stuff like that and now Owen
is still conscious but just barely
they asked him who did this to you and
he says nobody nobody right okay so they
asked him well how did this happen
and he said I fell against the bathtub
okay that was his acute like he was tied
up and beat ahead of his own but yeah so
he said I fell against the bathtub
they asked him if he tried to kill
himself which seemed like a dumb
question because house is a sock did you
try yourself
tie yourself up and [ __ ] like that and
he said no and then he started to go
unconscious they put him in an ambulance
and they take him to the hospital
however on the way to the hospital he
shuffled off his mortal coil
he got yes okay now the doctor thought
that because of the blood in the room
that the blood had been there for six or
seven hours because it had solidified
like on the walls and on his body was it
like that yes instantly it was I'm being
like I said it's 1935 so this to me
seems very weird because like I said the
first fell boy that went up there about
the phone I mean presumably he was right
next to the bed because he righted the
phone stand and put the phone back on it
he said yeah the guy was laying there
naked but he didn't said I say I saw
blood splatter everywhere like it was so
[ __ ] dark in there that he couldn't
see anything so that seemed a little
weird that they said that the blood was
all dried and solidified but it must
have been there for
seven hours so the doctor sighs now
another weird thing they said okay so
then the top are searched in the hotel
room and here's where it gets a little
strange it's not strange up until now
yeah but I mean Cola get stranger a
stranger over the whole case is [ __ ]
strange it I can like I might work for a
living and I love true crime and I try
to figure [ __ ] out I'm not been able to
figure this [ __ ] out this is cool
because like I said now it's getting
even weirder so the cops search the room
all they find it okay
first of all they find no clothes and if
you'll recall when he checked into the
Hat Val keypad Klose smoker they find
new clothes no shoes no underwear no
overcoat no nothing whoever killed him
took em of course I guess ya know
bloggers huh all they found in the room
they found a label from a necktie which
I don't know if he had been wearing a
tie at the beginning they found a
hairpin okay
a safety pin an unlighted cigarettes and
a small unused bottle of dilute sulfuric
acid what the hell's f work who knows
but it wasn't used I should also mention
that aside from all his clothes being
gone someone had also stolen everything
from the hotel room including all the
soap the shampoo the towels everything
there were no weapons in the room there
was nothing right so the only things
left in the room that the hotel provided
were two water glasses they you know
they were glass
they said one was still in the bathroom
on the shelf the other one was in the
sinks broken like with a shard of is
missing okay okay I don't know if they
ever found the shard or not now on the
telephone stand which had a glass top as
I mentioned before they were able to get
for fingerprints but they were small so
they're thinking they belong to a woman
so they don't know if this person was
the killer if this was the hooker right
this was some other woman that rose
who knows but they're presuming that
their woman's fingerprints because they
were small yeah so anyway man they're
from a long time yeah that it might not
have been I'm [ __ ] it could have been
the [ __ ] Bell boys from what he
brought he picked the telephone stand up
and you know maybe he was a young guy
and he's lying
so anyway so role Oh
I said that he died on the way to the
hospital he actually got the hospital
anyone to a coma and that he died but
yeah he did anyway then over the evening
they start trying to identify this guy
now the first thing they discover is
that clearly rollin t ohen is not his
real name because he says he's from Los
Angeles and they can find the record of
a roland com4 Los Angeles right now
here's ok so they they take the guy so
the guy is now a John Doe he's
unidentified so they take him to a
funeral home and they put him on display
and they tell people you know they put
out a thing in the paper or whatever or
on the radio to come and try and
identify this dude because now they have
no idea who the [ __ ] he is right now one
of the people that came to identify the
body as I mentioned earlier was Robert
Lane the guy that said he had picked
them up with the cut on his arm and for
some reason the cop didn't I don't know
they thought oh that wasn't the same
dude
even though Robert Lane came and said
yeah that's the guy and yeah there's
that cut on his arm that I wrong so I
don't know why the cops thought that it
was the same dude or I don't know it was
a it doesn't really say you know all
these people come and some people like
oh yeah that's my cousin or something
like that but you know it's they didn't
really identify him and they had they
put it on the wire services they took a
picture of him in the in the funeral
home and they put it out on the wire
services and asked people to come
forward if they recognize them now about
the only things they could determine
some people had seen him in a couple of
bars around the hotel in the pret and
the company of two women they went to
the mule aback hotel where he had
bitched about how
pay five dollars for an interior room
and they went there and they showed the
picture to the people that worked there
and the people that work there said yeah
that guy stayed here but rollin t ohen
wasn't his name he registered under the
name Eugene K Scott and he said he was
from Los Angeles so they ran that name
and there was no one named Eugene case
got from Los Angeles in Los Angeles
either so that clearly was not his name
either so then they um like later on
several days people came in people were
trying to identify him and [ __ ] like
that now on January 12th there's a guy
named Tony Bernardi and he was a
wrestling promoter and he came in and he
said this guy came into my wrestling
establishment whatever and he said a
couple weeks ago and he said that he
wanted to get in some wrestling matches
because like I said he had that ear so
people thought maybe he was a fighter
like a boxer or something like that
now this wrestling promoter said that
this man's name was Cecil Werner and he
said this guy told him he wrestled for
some other guide Omaha named Charles
blocks so they checked with Charles
Locke they show him pictures of the dude
and stuff like that
Charles Locke of Omaha has no idea who
this [ __ ] dude is no all right late
so time goes on and you know no one can
identify the dude they have no idea who
he is they have three different names
for this dude and none of them match up
no one recognizes them that comes there
it's like they have no [ __ ] idea
so finally March 3rd and they're like
void finally we're just going to bury
this dude and since he was a John Doe
they were going to bury him in you know
the potter's field where they very
unidentified people but then the funeral
home gets an anonymous phone call and
the caller says don't bury him in the
potter's field we're going to send you
enough money to cover the burial and the
funeral right so then on March 23rd the
funeral home gets a special delivery
envelope and inside it is a bunch of
money wrapped in newspaper
that's the killers on that yeah and it
was enough to pay for the funeral and
the burial I'm getting idea no right but
right but wait I'm not done Yara okay so
so the funeral home obviously thinking
this is a little weird they call the
police but they have the funeral they
had the burials they buried him in
Memorial Park Cemetery now I don't know
what name they buried him on her because
they don't know what his [ __ ]
negative like a couple days later an
unidentified woman called the newspaper
and she said Roland Owen was not buried
in the potter's field call The
Undertaker's and the florist and you'll
learn that mr. Owens funeral expenses
were paid and that a floral tribute was
placed on his grave now this floral
tributes see the same [ __ ] happens
an anonymous caller called the rock
flower company and they sent enough
money to buy a bouquet of 13 red roses
and they wanted these roses to say love
forever
Louise oka they have no idea to Louise's
well I think that's just a name that was
on right I'm just saying it might be the
Lewis no I know but my damn dude named
Lewis yeah I think it is I'm thinking
gave him a girl's name I'm thinking his
boyfriend killed it so anyway so when
they had the funeral I mean obviously
the cops thought oh maybe the killer
will show up or something like that so
the cops take it out unfortunately
nobody
uh nobody came to the funeral except the
cops right okay so you know they start
looking for they're looking for Don
they're looking for Louise they have no
idea who the [ __ ] any of these people
are right now eventually they did
identify the dude they think what ended
up happening was about a year and a half
later there had been um kind of an
expose at the case y'all right you know
okay there had been time an expose of
the case published in the American
Weekly it was a magazine and this woman
happened to see the story like about a
year
a half after has been published and she
sees the picture in there she said God
you know that looks just like my
friend's son who's been missing right so
she sends the magazine to the woman and
the woman sees the thing it she's like
yes that's my son he's been missing he
was from Birmingham Alabama and the
weird thing
now she identified him as her son that
he is like the most 1935 name ever
Artemus Ogletree that was his name
evidently according to his mother and
she said that he was only 17 years old
now she said that he had taken off like
two you know wander the country or
whatever it is seventeen year old boys
were doing in 1935 and she had been
trying to find him since she had even
like contacted J Edgar Hoover and also
she had heard that he'd gone to Cairo
and married somebody and she couldn't
find him right and so but she said the
weird thing was that she had received
three short hype written letters that
were supposedly from him
but she said even before and she got
these after he was already dead like she
didn't know he was dead and she said
even before she knew he was dead yes
that they probably weren't from him she
said one because he didn't know how to
type and two she said it just didn't
sound like him never felt like oh I'm
doing fine blah blah blah and all she
said it just didn't sound like a right
so but evidently they said that's what
was its Artemis Ogletree however that's
about like all they found out after that
was that um no wonder he's doing aliases
with a name like Artemis oh we need to
talk about this a [ __ ] ragnar he
sounds like he sounds like a
supervillain he may have been I don't
know but um the only thing they found
out like after that and like I said
they're assuming his mom identified as
they assumed that's really his dude was
arc Observatory right 17 years old and
they found out that he had also stayed
while he was in Kansas City presumably a
few days before he died he had stayed at
this other
hotel called the st. Regis and when he
checked in there he was with another
dude so they don't know if that was dawn
the guy he was talking to on the phone
or if it was some other dude or what
yeah now that is about that's all they
know that's it they have no idea who
[ __ ] killed this person they have no
idea why they killed the person why no
why why why so pretty good so the only
thing the only coda to this was sometime
in the 2000 somebody that worked in in a
like a library in Missouri they had the
records for this case right and they got
a phone call from out of state and this
person on the other end of the phone
said that they were going through an
elderly relative stuff you know that
after they had died and they said they
found this box and it had all of these
newspaper articles about this case yeah
and they said it in the Box also there
was an object court unquote that had
been mentioned in the papers at the time
but then they didn't tell me wasn't at
the library what the object was so
that's like what the [ __ ] man okay is it
missing shard glass that's I was just
going to say that is that exact same
thing yeah because it didn't really say
it said one of the glasses on a shard
missing but they didn't say they found
the shard ruff they said like I said all
they found in the room was the [ __ ]
label off the time a safety pin a hair
pin an unlighted cigarette and that
weird bottle of sulfuric acid which had
not been used so it's like did whoever
did they like bring it to the room like
they were going to use it and then they
didn't get away to do that yeah that's
like pretty much the whole case now this
right all right so like I said many
mysteries many mysteries one we were
pretty much for sure who this guy is 17
year old kid probably from Birmingham
Alabama if he is who his mother says it
ya know if that's him okay so like I
said who killed this person why his
boyfriend killed him well okay but the
weird thing is that nobody nobody really
saw anybody going in and out he must
have been hiding underneath the bed or
in the bathroom maybe he I don't have
room David yeah I didn't somebody kept
leaving they got into a fight
kill him and then I regretted it later
than heading very you know didn't want
very fancy he must have been I think he
ran away from home when he was about 17
cuz he was gay so he's old
yeah back in 1935 that's why I wanted to
wanted a room interior there's no
windows no one could see what's going on
him and this guy didn't have a job
where's the money coming from
yeah even if somebody was taking care of
him that's what I'm kind of wondering
about like I you know I don't want to
miss Burch the man who makes merch the
member every night I've heard but you
know probably most of the family members
is dead by now but um I kind of have to
think that he might have been a gigolo
well that could be food or something
like that yeah because well here's the
thing now that I think if the hotels
were said not other guys coming and
going all night long in his room right
and here's another weird thing now let's
the maid that kept going up and bringing
towels and cleaning his room and stuff
she said that when she first saw him and
every time she saw him she does he was
always hitting in the dark she's like
and even though he talked to her
sometimes she said he always looked kind
of worried but the thing is how worried
could he have been if he kept leaving
the [ __ ] door unlocked grapefruit
boyfriend and he even told the maid
don't want the door don't lock the door
like someone's coming so it wasn't like
he was afraid someone was gonna come and
kill him his boyfriend was a psycho
he was an abused man you think ya don't
like that like why I don't think it was
anything you know it's an interesting
case but I don't think it was anything
you know bizarre yeah have you seen it
go down it would have been Monday we'll
see but that's it well that's what I was
telling you today that's that's true of
every unsolved murder Brooke but the
intriguing thing is that you weren't
there
and all you know is like all these like
weird little details at the end right
and you have no idea like why I mean
like I said this isn't kind of I don't
think this is kind of the casework
because you know how we did the show we
did the show on a summer command and
install woman yes and those two murders
I think they were probably secret agents
right because that was some really like
cold work a type of [ __ ] cold whatever
[ __ ]
this guy I don't know like it seems like
like I said it seems like he must have
been involved in something kind of seedy
like maybe he ran away from home like I
said maybe it was kind of like a you
know what was the what the [ __ ] is that
Drugstore Cowboy or whatever the [ __ ] is
that
yeah what a nice cowboy whatever movie
good at midnight now it might be a
situation like that where he's like well
I'm gonna leave the elevator man maybe
his burger was it to write it so maybe
it was something like that but like why
I don't know that one why would they
torture him well no they just said it
looked like that maybe just he might
have been trying to get to leave so he
was very tidy about you know just got a
lover's quarrel money might've been
another wrestler that he was messing
well and what about they were violent
yeah and it didn't take a shirt off of
our level we know wrestle each other
yeah you know for years and also like
who he was apparently seen in some bars
with two women
yeah and the woman in the neighboring
work room said that she heard arguing it
was two men and two women she said it
sounded like but nobody saw these women
try to rescue him maybe the only other
the only other woman that anybody saw
like any of the himself soft
saw was the hooker breasts and that was
one woman right and she was a hooker
because like I said they the staff had
seen her around before and like after
she went up to the 10th floor and said
oh I don't know where that dude is and
then she went out and then she came back
with a different thing than when I do a
different floor I can't answer Jenny I
don't know you don't have any like have
any schedule a chinois I said respected
I think I you did boyfriend guilders
okay well so lay it out what do you what
do you think exactly happened we got
every bond and boyfriend yeah she said
he was like a freeze abusive you know I
mean he was coming and going all the
time you know and when people were not
going to door he either need the bed you
had the hookers trying to rescue him
getting him out of this abusive
relationship arrest Shawn it's going to
be something like that
hey anybody invited heat and heat broken
glass and took a glass shard
caught on him a little bit with it
something like that I don't know you
know I'm not a detective
just it's kind of odd though that nope I
mean if he was indeed being tortured in
there it was Labor know that he knew him
well yeah yeah but whoever it was
polygon yeah and like I said they never
did find on they never did like figure
out who Louise was well they never did
figure out who these I think we're
calling I think Louise was done I think
it was just could write dawn hey you
know goodness dog then he's been talking
to you on maybe I was cover name when he
was dressing dragged he called sup
Louise holy crap you just like made a
hole son really but no for real they
should they should make a movie out of
this I think like I said the weirdest
details to me or one that everything was
gone in the room they took all his [ __ ]
they not only took all his [ __ ] but they
took all the hotel [ __ ] - they took all
the soap and everything you say [ __ ]
like five not today yeah like at 30
seconds see any people ha ha ha all this
extra swearing it's like you know
another swearing or not swearing there's
never extra sweater are you precisely so
much swearing as it says right there in
our commercial this show is rated on
you're offended by you know common
vernacular and and swearing you sneeze
you don't need to be listening to it
well that's true because I can't I
generally I can't I want some [ __ ]
about playing we're not going to get
into a time machine and go back to 1955
we're know once we're go back we'll
watch television that's it that's the
deal
Leave It to Beaver I can't talk about it
anymore we can't talk about anymore all
right
okay so well if you guys get better days
but I you know I think he's a gigolo I
mean just somebody's boyfriend I think
he's a jealous because like I said what
if they don't know if this was the same
guy like they don't know if he was
staying with the same guys at st. Regis
they don't know if that was done or not
might been differently you never never
going to know why since all I know well
I know that's why that's why it's so
intriguing because one whatever ended up
like I said they did find out later on
who it was
artim adultery no that was never really
decided either remember - it's like
maybe he'd have the body she didn't I do
Bob yeah she was studied for my picture
right oh yeah so if you guys have any
ideas because I'm kind of curious to see
if anybody has any ideas about what the
fuss is to be all about I like foreign
leaders yeah yeah I did
then let us know in the comments or
email me or whatever I don't care and
you know show me to figure it out
because I think I think I might put this
in my upcoming book my true crime book
how many of these can you put into a
book I mean I don't know if I got my
[ __ ] done okay I'm sure I'll find like
ponds of different one and like I said
this this one kind of interested me
because like I said it it was like one
of the most popular ones on that
particular subreddit that I had never
heard of it then I started reading it
I'm like how the [ __ ] that I never hear
about this and like I said it was it was
in like a cracked article and this same
cracked article also has this great
[ __ ] story well not great but you
know he had this great [ __ ] story
about a pretty recent I guess it was a
murder like in Pennsylvania this little
boy coming on the school bus and he
found a severed head that had little
Robbie's lover bliss little rubber
bouncy balls in the eye socket yeah he
couldn't maneuver ideas no it was an old
woman's head and the head had been
embalmed yeah I think it was I think it
was a medical craft
maybe maybe it fell off the truck
imagine nobody was looking yeah like the
funny the funny I don't think it was all
the drug I think suits - stole it
remember like bouncy balls and he just
has a head he stole a head off of this
medical cadavers hey you know that's the
thing that they throw you got drunk food
out the window the cars just like that
urban legend about those medical
students that like stolen stolen arm off
a cadaver and then they went through
like a coal booth and then they use the
cadaver arms or like hands and - I don't
know if that's true or not but it's an
urban legend but anyways okay so we're
gonna say reckless we're getting to the
end of the show so at the end of the
show as usual we like to remind
everybody to go to the project
Entertainment Network patreon which is
patreon.com slash project sense
and give them a couple of bucks also if
you like our show then go to our
Facebook page and like us go follow us
on Twitter at what the [ __ ] is name of
our show oh yeah
like 13 o'clock I can buy some cool
shirt go buy some shirts I've got those
shirts too and also you know subscribe
to our YouTube channel and all that good
stuff
and that'll do it for this episode this
scary horror in room 1046 somebody
figure it out goddamn because it's
bugging me
do it o musical interlude okay well I'm
not going to I'll let it be a surprise
yeah okay so that'll do it for this
week's show so about hotel yeah okay I'm
not yet okay okay no you don't know you
don't die don't okay All Right see you
guys next week bye
[Music]
[Music]
the end oh no please
[Music]
[Music]